foreign
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the journalist and broadcaster Jenny
kleeman and the deputy editor of
conservative home Henry Hill they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages
the guardian leads with the government
being accused of attempting a cover-up
of messages sent during the pandemic
which it's now been given two extra days
to hand over to the covert inquiry
The Mirror Has that story too and
pictures Boris Johnson out for a jog
today with the headline running and
hiding
according to the eye scientists and
Technology experts have warned
artificial intelligence could lead to
the extinction of humanity
that story also making the front page of
the Daily Mail and the times also makes
it their top story tomorrow too the sun
returns to the Phillips Schofield Saga
with news that his former co-presenter
Holly Willoughby will be back on this
morning next Monday
the express reports that civil servants
intend to strike over the government's
plan to deport migrants to Rwanda
the Metro has the story of a teacher who
lost his job after making a social media
post aimed at four teenagers he claimed
had threatened to harm his wife
according to the financial times the
re-elected Turkish president recep tire
erdogan erdogan is being lobbied by
Western Nations to vote to admit Sweden
to Nato
and the star has the story of a whale
that some people claim has been trained
as a Russian spy
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers well you
watch us
and of course we're joined tonight by
Jenny cleeman and Henry Hill great to
see you both thanks so much for joining
us and certainly uh that's warning that
very Stark warning about artificial
intelligence leading on many of the
front pages uh Jenny let's kick off with
the front page of the eye their headline
all creators
AI creators I should say fear the
extinction of humanity
yeah this is quite a headline uh this is
because industry uh leaders Godfathers
of AI plus the CEOs of open AI Google
deepmind and and lots of really
influential thinkers in this space put
out this extraordinary 23-word statement
today saying essentially that the the
potential dangers of AI and it is
potential dangers it's not the current
dangers but the potential dangers of AI
should be considered on on par with
pandemics and uh the threat of nuclear
war and this is something that that
thinkers in this space have been saying
for quite a long time but the fact that
you have these CEOs also signing this
letter is very significant because the
issue is not what uh language models
like chat GPT could do now it's not
about uh AIS taking our jobs it's about
the fact that they're learning at a pace
um that is kind of worrying the people
who even developed these models and it's
good that we're having these questions
now because at the moment they are not
an existential threat to us but for
example if we are using AIS to develop
drugs we have to make sure that we
couldn't use them to develop chemical
weapons for example or bioengineered
viruses
um we need to make sure that we optimize
them to have our values rather than
their own set of of values we need to
make sure that we're not relying on them
to such an extent that if they have bugs
in them or if they go down that we are
incredibly vulnerable and even with
language models like chat GPT the the
CEO of open AI only a few weeks ago was
was warning about the the dangers of for
example being able to ask an AI who
should I vote for who's better on the on
the economy so the fact is we need to
have some sort of Regulation it is
possible it happened in biotech for
example we don't clone human beings even
though it's technologically possible and
this is just a way of having that
discussion putting that on the table and
yes it leads to lots of Terminator type
of headlines but in fact it's just a
sensible precautionary thinking given
the state of the software at the moment
and Henry that the Daily Mail also
leading uh on this story tomorrow with a
bit more detail on their uh front page
but certainly uh it's these experts in
artificial intelligence people who
founded it and developed it who know it
best who are issuing these Stark
warnings
yeah absolutely and the the male sort of
teases out the difference between the
sort of slightly science fictiony rise
of the Machines style threat that people
like Elon Musk have talked about and the
threat talked about by most of the
people who signed this letter which is
much more basically AI being used to
enhance dangerous stuff that humans are
already doing so for example Jenny
mentioned chemical weapons this is in
fact I believe already happened they
developed an AI model uh to look at
chemistry and try and work out new
antidotes and then somebody thought okay
what happens if we flip that round what
if we ask it to do the opposite and it
developed uh some incredibly potent uh
neurotoxins and toxins including some of
the ones that already exist and are some
of the most dangerous in the world today
so that's the danger the difficulty is
that you know most of this stuff if it's
being used of AI is being used it's
going to be used as I said for stock
humans we're already doing and that
means it's very hard to coordinate
because ultimately while there are
exceptions such as some areas of Biotech
fundamentally when you've got countries
like China in the United States at
loggerheads there's very huge barriers
to creating a real Global framework and
if one set of powers or power worries
that the other is using this technology
to try and get a leg up in whatever
field the Temptation is going to be
there to do the same and that's how you
end up with a kind of arms race so the
danger is real the danger is mostly that
it just makes humans much more effective
at working out ways to destroy the human
race which they're already pretty good
at but the difficulty is how do you get
everyone who could potentially use this
dangerously to get around the table and
agree not to do that
yeah let's move on to another story
that's on some of the front pages
tomorrow Jenny the guardian leading on
this story of Boris Johnson's WhatsApp
messages the cabinet office have been
given another two days to produce this
material for the covert inquiry but
certainly it's not a good look is it
that the government's withholding uh
this material but certainly the
government feels it has some grounds to
protect the privacy of ministers tell us
more
well wish you seen that as the guardian
says is is being accused of attempting
to cover up the actions of ministers
during the pandemic uh this is after
um the cabinet office has uh refused to
hand over the unredacted whatsapps
um and Diaries and notebooks of Boris
Johnson to the covert inquiry even even
though they were requested
um and for me this is quite astonishing
because I would imagine if I was a
minister if I had been a minister during
covid which we all viscerally felt was
an extraordinary time I would feel that
everything that I wrote down or typed
into my phone would be a matter of
public record and would be disclosed
well within the 30 years that that is
normally the kind of moratorium on
public documents being disclosed Boris
Johnson apparently has said that uh he's
happy for um his notebooks whatsapps and
and Diaries to be disclosed that it's
the cabinet office apparently that is
being obstructive thus far the cabinet
officer has said that it doesn't see the
point of uh giving over things that
would be irrelevant to the inquiry but
then it's making the Judgment call of
what's relevant to the inquiry which is
surely uh one for uh the people leading
the inquiry uh to make so it's not great
uh particularly at a time when we really
do need transparency over something that
we all have a stake in we all want to
know whether or not what was done uh was
in in the public interest when it came
to us sacrificing massive personal
freedoms it matters very much and at the
moment it yes it doesn't look very good
for Rishi Cena Henry your thoughts are
on all of this certainly if you're a
minister and you're carrying out
government business on WhatsApp you can
expect for your WhatsApp messages to
perhaps be requested at some point
well I think part of the problem is that
that wasn't was never I think previously
entirely clear and there is this sort of
post Freedom of Information Act arms
race where ministers looking for places
you know and officials looking for
places to deliberate in private move
further and further away from the
official channels in an attempt to do
that and therefore the lines of the
official channels are gradually drawn
more and more broadly to try and keep up
with them which I don't think helps
anybody so the government's got a few
lines here so which is slightly
confusing the the cabinet office insists
simultaneously that it just wants to not
send over stuff that isn't relevant and
also According to some media reports
that it doesn't actually have the
information I don't see how both of
those could be true
um most interestingly Sir James Edie the
the treasury devil one of the
government's most senior lawyers has
said that actually there's a case that
this is uh the communications between
ministers are protected by cabinet
Collective responsibility which mandates
that there has to be a private space for
free and Frank discussion between
ministers I think that's an interesting
argument and we'll have to see where
that goes ultimately what's at stake
here is Boris Johnson is being asked to
hand over all of his WhatsApp
Communications with 40 people and that
will include not just official you know
what we might consider of the official
business but also everything else that
they said and he'll be worried that
those will be leaked we don't know how
many people will see this information it
seems unlikely that the the chair of the
inquiry will review all of this
information personally so there are
important things at stake here because
transparency is an important principle
but on the other hand you do need
government to have the space to have um
Frank discussions and there's a reason
that the 30-year rule later the 20-year
rule existed in the first place and that
is attention that we do have to resolve
Jenny I've seen you shaking ahead at
some of what Henry's been saying now a
brief thought from you
think you can have private discussions
you ring people up to talk to have
private discussions I think you know I'm
an investigative journalist right at the
beginning of Learning my craft I was
told that you should expect that
anything you write down will be
disclosed in court
um you you know that when you type
things or write them down they're going
to be disclosed it shouldn't it
surprised you and I don't think it gets
it's a barrier to um being able to have
a Frank discussion the fact that
disclosure might happen if you know you
can have conversations on the phone and
yes they might be recorded but there's
not the same compulsion to to disclose
that there is of a diary or a notebook
okay Jenny Henry uh we'll give you a bit
of a breather and and see you again in a
moment uh do stay with us because we'll
have more of the front pages coming up
next including the front page of the
Guardian is Keith making a tactical and
political Mistake by launching drone
attacks on Moscow we'll be discussing
that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me now Jenny Cleveland and
Henry Hill good to see you both again
Henry let's kick off with you uh this
time front page of the express civil
servants are threatening to strike uh
over migrants MPS have demanded the
sacking of civil servants according to
the express who are considering strike
action over their plans to deport
migrants to Rwanda tell us more
yeah so essentially the home office is
the Department of all the Departments
where the government's apparent
confrontation and difficulties with the
salt service has been most acute and
today the Civil Service Union has
reported has announced that staff are
planning to go on strike because they
think that the Rwanda policy is unlawful
under international law now this is
problematic because it inevitably gets
slightly technical the UK is basically
what's called a dual estate
international law has no legal standing
in this country unless given effect by
an act of parliament so if the Rwanda
policy is the government's policy and it
has been passed by an act of parliament
there really is no basis for civil
servants in other agents of the state to
claim that international law is an equal
or even Superior law and therefore to
defy orders on that basis it's very
tricky politically for the government
you know you can call for mass sackings
of civil servants but then you have to
you know replace them with people and
it's not obvious that the government
could do that quickly but ultimately the
strike I think the justification for the
strike is deeply misguided but it does
show the sheer difficulty the Practical
difficulty the government is having in
carrying forward what it its immigration
policy
and Jenny your thoughts on this
certainly uh it will do nothing to
improve uh relations between civil
servants and ministers
yeah relations between civil servants
and ministers are at an all-time low uh
many conservative ministers and
commentators making much of the Civil
Service woke blob getting in the way of
the will of government to uh to carry
out uh the policies that that they are
have been have been elected to carry out
and you know this is off the back of
Dominic Robb lost his job uh over his
bullying allegations and claimed there
were sort of activists civil servants
um trying to push their agenda uh in the
way of ministerial business the fact is
that ministers need to be able to work
with civil servants and civil servants
need to be able to work with with
ministers there has to be a way around
this rather than MPS threatening to sack
striking civil servants
um when they don't agree on on on policy
although they're not supposed to agree
or disagree on policy or whether on the
legality of of policy
um this is a sign I think of of bad
leadership in government for things to
be so bad between a civil service and
government in order for this country to
function properly
um they have to be able to work together
do I detect you shaking your head there
Henry
Jenny Jenny's point is generally true I
think that lots of conservatives make
way too much of the route of civil
servants and often it's it's a cover for
ministers who simply aren't good at
getting policy done and they blame this
kind of incoher civil service conspiracy
but I think this case is different this
is a case of what is quite clearly a
politically motivated strike uh on the
basis that civil servants should not
have to carry out policies with which
they a disagree on the basis that it is
in breach of international law which as
I said has no standing in this country I
think it's important to separate the
specific facts of this case from the
broader problem okay I'm going to jump
in there because I really want to get to
uh the Ukraine uh story front page of
the Guardian Journey certainly it felt
like a a very significant moment in the
war today uh with that drone attack on
moscow's suburbs
um yes it's it's enormous uh you know
many drones attacking a Moscow Southern
Suburban affluent suburb where Vladimir
Putin himself has a home it's a
significant uh breach of Russian
defenses and as much as the Moscow mayor
tried to uh play it down and the defense
Ministry uh said it was eight drones it
may have been 17 drones uh that they've
all been shot down
um it's really worrying for Vladimir
Putin because he's of course sold the
war in Ukraine uh as a way of keeping
Russia safer to his people and now
Russians I think feel scared we saw lots
of Clips on social media of ordinary
Russians really terrified about this and
it's also we don't know who's behind it
many analysts say they very much believe
that Ukraine is behind it this is after
Kiev has been facing you know drone
attack after drone attack for nights
nights on end
um but the really significant thing is
this is a huge risk if Ukraine is behind
this it risks the support of of European
allies because it is an incursion into
Russian territory and Ukraine has said
they're not going to use foreign weapons
in Russia but there's nothing to stop
them uh using their own so potentially
this is a very significant moment yeah
Jenny Henry it's been great to have you
with us we'll see you again next hour
thanks so much